[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA Steven spilburg in
this video we're breaking down Back to
the Future the movie Kick started one of
the best trilogies of all time and today
we're going to be going through it scene
by scene selected by the film registry
for film preservation this is easily one
of the best movies ever made and I can't
wait to talk about it pretty much
everyone to know who went to film School
in love with this movie and the script
Su it's taught in almost every
University this is something where
almost every line in has a payoff at
some point and I was blown away when
revisiting it with a a loser YouTuber
breakdown at more critical eye to it so
come with me Morty sorry
Marty as we travel to the past and talk
about Back to the
Future you son of a [__] I'm in and the
film popped up as an idea in Bob Gail's
head when he was one day going through
his dad's so yearbook seeing his pops as
a team made him think about his past and
what life must have being like when he
was in school being a dad myself like I
feel like my kids will remember how cool
I was or or they'll either think that or
just what a [__] [__] it's something
that we as kids often don't wonder about
our parents either and all the wild
things we've done our parents probably
did too when I was your age I never
chased a boy or called a boy or sat in a
parked car with a boy already am almost
18 years old it's not like I've never
parked
before what so that was a [__] lie
going wild at parties Petty vandalism
not hitting the thumbs up all those bad
things that we've done they probably
also did too our parents had a time
before we were born to where they
probably weren't burdened with glorious
purpose now this had girl thinking that
if he had a time machine he'd go back
and see his dad to see if they'd become
friends Marty and George share somewhat
similarities with them both having
dreams that they want to achieve George
is obsessed with becoming a rider and
mody just wants to play the guitar on
stage George for not achieving his goals
has somewhat had an effect on his son
but in the end both get their time in
the Limelight I can't guess you guys
aren't ready for that yet but your kids
are going to love it telling this idea
to Rober zakus the pieces started to
fall in place and when Spielberg wasn't
board the ball really got rolling gayen
zamus created a draft in 1980 with them
saying they wanted to do something
different than what had come before you
see typically time travel movies they
showed the past as being a fixed Point
whereas the pair had the idea that
things could be changed
there actually a number of different
things that alter in the film which
we'll talk more about as we go through
the movie still though the first draft
was was a far cry from what we got with
the DeLorean being completely absent
that had the time machine being a room
with a laser-like device that helped
with the time travel when I hear about
it I I kind of Imagine The ttis and
apparently this device then got put
inside a fridge this was then taken out
to an atomic bomb test with that being
the basis of how to get home however
Spielberg right Spielberg he apparently
worried that kids right might start
climbing inside their fridges and this
would make some believe they could use
one to survive a nuke years later we
we'd see something similar in Indiana
Jones dear M just cracked up a bit
learning that anyway the time machine
was going to be made by a corporation
but Seas felt an individual was going to
act better the say looked at real life
figures such as Einstein who doc Brown's
dog would later be named after Einstein
died during 1955 and his theory of
relativity is used for the time machine
test Einstein theorized that motion
caused time to move differently which
meant meant that a clock moving would
tick slightly faster than one that's
just stationary I think for God's sakes
Jim I'm a YouTuber not a physicist after
a number of revisions the DeLorean got
brought in as its design had an almost
other worldly field this also had
inspiration from other time machines
with the interface being based on the
time machine film from the 1960s this
had the panels on the machine being
green red and yellow with those colors
also coming across to the panel in the
car the the car was then going to be
driven into the atomic bomb test but
this was eventually removed purely
because of the budget that you can catch
a couple of nods to it as the van the
delorean's first roll that of has a
bumper sticker on it this says one
nuclear bomb can ruin your whole day
also a disclaimer I keeps say nuclear
wrong in every single video um I did
used to do an impression of a Russian
guy go I must have nuclear weapons and
since then it's stuck and I'm just keep
ruining my videos even more and more do
not watch my Oppenheimer breakdown I
find your proposal M acceptable at the
end when mty speeds Back to the Future
we can also see the cinemas playing the
atomic kid according to the wiki there
were several of the ideas that didn't
make the car with Mod's actions
drastically changing the80s instead of
coming home to where he pretty much left
things the entire planet would have
hoverboards and flying cars we all know
from our own history we wouldn't get
those until 2015 but but his moves
changed it to that now George was also
going to be a famous boxer which led out
from him knocking out beff after saving
L rain however remnants of this plot
line still remain in the film with Marty
carrying a punching bag into George's
Back Garden this then led into a deleted
scene and it would have Marty giving him
boxing lessons and finally figuring out
he was a lefty throughout the film he
writes with his right hand but in the
end he punches with his left the Better
Health Website did a big report about
how kids used to be encouraged to write
with their right because left-handed
this was seen as being awkward most
things were built with right-handers in
mind and there was a big push against
this being adopted in the ' 50s so
George striking Biff with his left was
finally him shrugging off the life he'd
been bullied into and standing up for
who he was in more ways than
one a universal head said shinberg
didn't like the title due to the word
future being in it he said they should
change it to space man from Pluto
because reasons I guess man wanted this
my name is Darth Vader I am an
extraterrestrial from the planet Vulcan
change to I am spaceman from Pluto but
Spiel B did something that shut that
idea down he sent him a note saying ah
mate what a what a what a great joke
that was hey what a [__] great joke
you did there mate almost thought you
were being serious you [__] which
shinberg was way too embarrassed to
fight back on he's made you look a right
knob now production for the film was hit
with a couple of snags and I'm sure you
all know this story about Eric stz this
even got referenced recently in the
flash when they were talking about who's
starting back to the future I know I've
seen all of them and Eric staltz is not
Marty McFly they explain Marty mcai here
now what happened is that he was playing
Marty and malora Harden was playing
Jennifer so we could have had an
alternate timeline with Jan from the
office but in the end she got let go too
Fox had actually always been the first
choice for Marty but he couldn't make it
due to his contract with Family Ties you
see Meredith Baxter was pregnant at the
time and this fox needed to appear in
the show more than usual ual stals was
cast but things weren't working and on
said he said to have been very difficult
to work with man apparently refused to
answer to anything other than Marty and
this was so bad that when he was told
he'd been fired Christopher lyd said
who's Eric I thought he was called Marty
IMDb trivia also says that Tom Wilson
who plays be almost got his collar bone
broken during the lunchroom scenes Tom
asked him toone it down but stals just
kept going and he caused lots of
difficulties everyone knew that he
wasn't right for the roll and after 6
weeks of shooting Baxter had returned to
Family Ties stals was then called into a
room and killed sorry sorry he was
called in and told he wasn't right and
apparently stals also agreed too Harden
was then let go because she was too tall
to play against Fox and The Producers
had realize that size Matters that's
what she
saidel thus they managed to work
something out with Fox but it still
sounds like it was a really grueling
shoot Fox would film Family Ties in the
day and then dve over to the set and
work from 6:00 till 6: all the scenes
shot in the daytime they were done on
the weekends with everything working out
all right in the end also I'm DB trivia
yeah says that stals went on to play the
fly in the Fly 2 who was called Martin
so he went from playing Marty McFly to
Martin the
fly nice nice when they they include a
joke you can steal and there's still a
shot of stals left in the film but this
own change in the timeline drastically
changed the outcome anyway that's the
making of
which takes us into the movie itself now
let us go back to the
[Music]
future That's The Power of
Love Now a famous phrase in film is show
don't tell boil down to its Basics it
means that film's a visual medium and
it's often better to convey something
with images rather than a character
telling us what's happening now why I'm
telling you this and not showing you is
to talk about the opening shot which
convey
so much information it's one of the best
openings to a film ever the doc Browns
we begin looking at several clocks which
are all set to 753 later on we learned
that this was part of an experiment
perfect my experiment worked they're all
exactly 25 minutes slow and one of the
only clocks that's correct is the one on
the floor which is currently set to 818
this subtly gives the idea that docks
been messing with time and we also have
two different time periods here now as
we move through the room we see some
decorative clocks including one with a
drunk man slumped up against it this
kind of reminds me of the homeless guy
that Marty Sees at the end when he
finally returns back to the future he
said it he said it this guy is actually
the character exm red Thomas whose
election trucks we see moving through
the 50s in the 80s the May's Goldie
Wilson whose truck we also see moving
through two bringing these moments full
circle shout out to Eric for his video
on the Deep dive for poting out that the
way the bum swigs the bottle here is
also similar to what Lorraine does in
the car l later on with myty we also get
an odd to harl Lloyd Safety First when
we see a small figure hanging from a
clock this is of course foreshadowing
the moment in the climax where
Christopher Lloyd hangs off the clock
tower doing this ends of breaking the
ledge which is another cool detail that
appears in the film when Jennifer and
Marty sit in front of it at the
10-minute 30 Mark we can see the ledge
behind them is absolutely fine however
in 1955 the dark ends up breaking it
which is something that then goes on to
affect the future C to the hour 41 Mark
and we get a hell opter flying by and
can see that the ledge has now been
broken off now from this clock we then
go past one that has the word regulator
on it before then going down to some
newspaper clippings this says that the
brown Mansion was destroyed and that the
estate was sold to developers Bob Gail
spoke about this on the commentary and
said this was all sold after funder's
time travel research Al so huge shout
outs to mudron on Reddit who pointed out
why the doc's Mansion might have burned
down later on after dark us this's fire
extinguisher we can see that this leaves
it almost completely empty so man
probably had an experiment that went
haywire but he'd overuse the
extinguisher and couldn't put it out
Safety
First next we move down to photos of
Edison and Benjamin Franklin the two of
which well one of which was a famous
inventor Franklin carried out an
experiment with a kite in the wind which
was struck by lightning like what
happens at the end later on Doc can be
seen talking to a picture which he
refers to as being Thomas this is
actually Thomas Edison calling back to
the photo that we see here now next to
them is also a picture of Einstein who
as we mentioned played a part in Doc's
inspiration on top of this was also
Leopold Stasi who was also used as a way
to style his look underneath this is the
JBC camera that later gets used to film
The First Time Travel attempt next to
this is also a Burger King cup with
rappers just littering the room now when
mody ends up leaving Doc's lab we can
see his garage backs onto a Burger King
restaurant explaining why there's so
many rappers in the House the TV is then
turned on by one of the clocks but this
one has to have had the right time this
is like this purely to show us the
report and this is where we learn of the
plutonium theft Duck's been out and
about and hasn't been home hence why we
then see the dog food piling up in an
already full bowl at this point we watch
his mod ENT is and he rolls his
skateboard over to the plutonium box so
those shots they tell us so much info
that it's hard to argue how good this
scene is now from this point we cut to
an amp interface which we can see
labeled crm114
this is actually an artist Stanley curi
who's used the number in a lot of his
films including Doctor Strange Love
where it was on the radio system blowing
up the amp my man's he make an entrance
and it's at this point the film really
gets going now as Marty skates outside
we sees he hitches a ride and then
travels through the town center of Hill
Valley this shot is later repeated in
1955 which just goes to show how times
change over the decades if you've ever
moved away from somewhere and then gone
back you'll have no doubt seen how even
a couple of decades all things I love
this place being a central location as
it perfectly demonstrates the
differences between the 50s and 80s now
as he goes down the main street we can
see there's two signs with Goldie
Wilson's name on them hinting at the
character we're going to meet later on
there's also lots of adult entertainment
spots and theaters and a better than
what it was like when when red Thomas
was running it mate also I wonder if red
and Goldie being colors shows that the
Mayes have a theme to them and maybe the
guy with the adult theaters is called
Blu-ray Hey cuz he sells adult movies
Blu-ray hey [__] sake now the name
Hill Valley that was chosen because it's
an oxymoron and that means it just
sounds like your bug standed town where
they cared so little about naming it
they chose two things that don't even
make sense down the line I'll talk about
how these shots are repeated through the
rest of the trilogy and yes you're right
I will be covering all the
films let's go if that's something
you're interested in then please smash
the Subscribe button and I'll see you
back in the future when I release them
soon now driving the truck we see a man
turn around who's rocking what's totally
not some Mountain Dew product placement
this is actually stun coordinator Walter
Scott who put this scene together cuz
the man's all about safety
first now from here mody skates up to
the school where we can catch some
graffiti on the wall next to a tree you
can see Lorraine Del Calvin which
foreshadows the fake name mod uses with
his mumler rain I was wondering if this
graffiti was from 1955 but that means
the school wouldn't have been cleaned
since then instead I I just think it's a
little in joke for when the set
decorators were putting this less than
pristine look together after bumping
into principal Strickland he says now
let me give you Nichols with a free
advice young man the so-called Dr Brown
is dangerous he's a real nutcase now you
might be wondering why a high schooler
is hanging around with an old man you
see r that store pleas sure look let let
me explain Chris you see you say Bob
Gail was speaking to the sight Mental
Floss and he talked about how the pair
met he said for years Marty was told
that Doc Brown was dangerous a crackpot
a lunatic Marty snuck into Doc's lab and
was fascinated by all the cool stuff
that was there when douc found him there
he was delighted to find that Marty
thought he was cool and accepted him for
what he was you see M stayed with him
because he got to use his guitar and
it's all just one big
misunderstanding the Poli the police are
wait waiting for me outside aren't they
[__] and the principal rattles off how
he's just like his dad and how no McFly
ever amounted to anything yeah well
history is going to change it's a nice
little line of dialogue that then leads
us into M's audition here they play The
Power of Love by huie Lewis in the news
with hu himself playing the teacher
carrying out the audition huie initially
just wrote this song but the creative
team weren't exactly thrilled with it
since it didn't really time with the
movie they said they needed one more
that was in line with the plot and after
showing him the film The Band made back
in time which is another Banger now on
stage we see M playing play alongside a
guy who looks a bit like Donnie tette
but this is actually Michael J Fox's
guitar instructor behind the scenes
shots of this have been shown on the
Blu-rays making a nice little Cameo for
the guy who helped him learn it at the
clock tower Marty talks about how he's
too scared to send his audition tape in
but Jennifer then drops this line it's
like dark yeah I know I know if you put
your mind to it you can accomplish
anything which is something that appears
throughout the film with a person who
relays the message getting the credit
for it at different points you know if
you put your mind to it you can
accomplish anything like I've always
told you you put your mind to it you can
accomplish anything lots of timey why me
wibbly wobbly stuff with Doc Brown
telling mty who then told his father and
then told him bringing things full
circle also I love how mty just checked
out the girls at walk past him and it's
literally that mean with a man getting
distracted get out of here kid you got
no future I mean I just don't think I
can take that kind of rejection this
lying about him having no future adome
subtext to the plot as we're meant to
worry that Marty might not get back
what right here right now in the
cafeteria what if she said no I don't
know if I could take that kind of a
rejection around the area you might have
also noticed that there's businesses
closing down and it seems like it's a
dying City Center on the bench we can
catch a sign for Z's Jewelers which says
that it's now in the Twin Pine Mall this
shows that the businesses are moving up
there and it sets up one of the main
locations that appears in the story on
top of this we can also catch two women
petitioning to save the clock tower this
headline documents how it was struck by
lightning with one of the women telling
him and got struck in 1955 and stopped
at that exact moment this gives Marty
all he needs to know so he can use his
info to power up the time machine
however Mar's distracted by a 4x4 which
is what he later ends up getting bought
by his parents someday
Jennifer someday Mar's dream of taking
Jennifer up to the lake in that truck is
something that he gets to do at the end
but here it seems like it's just a pipe
dream just above the women we can also
see a sign that says ask Mr Foster
travel since 1888 this shop's clearly
been around for a long time and we can
also catch it at the hour 41 Mark in
1955 though you can't see it here we
have other shots of the sign for this
that says time to travel which is he
it's a little time travel joke that at
this point Jennifer writes down her
number which begins with 5555 indicating
that it's completely fictional stop stop
ringing it huge shout outs to webborn on
Reddit for pointing out that Duc Brown's
number is kondik 54385 with K andl both
being on the five digigit meaning the
number is actually 5552 Al so as Mary
puts it away you can see you can see the
theater behind them showing ory American
style make make sure you subscribe to
the channel to watch us breakdown that
as well shabow anyway if you're a fan of
these classic movie breakdowns then you
definitely need to check out our
partners at Aro film they remaster a ton
of movies and release them on 4K Blu-ray
giving you the best version of the film
that you can possibly get right now
they're selling carry inovasion of the
Body Snatchers with a special edition
also coming soon they're out for
pre-order but if you want something
already on the site then you'll get 10%
off with the Cod heavy spoilers use the
code heavy spoilers to get some money
off these great movies and huge thank
you for all you guys support at this
point Marty hitches his way back home to
Lion estate where we see the outside of
his house later on we get a better shot
of this where Biff hasn't smashed
George's car like it's a like button now
a cool detail back in 1955 is that mody
comes across a billboard of what these
homes will look like placing next to the
shot we see at the end it actually lines
up really nicely with the way the real
house looks George's car being wrecked
is also just toos nicely at the end as
here Biff crashes it whereas there he's
cleaning it a and look uh now Biff I
want to make sure that we get two coats
of wax this time that just W don't con
me you look closely at where Biff's
waxing yet you can see hasn't even
finished the first coat up yet and he's
just putting that on now you don't don't
try to C me Biff now inside the house
George is a lot more like his 1950s V
verion with him having the slick back
Reesa hair and pocket protector this
shows he never really grew out of that
state and is sort of just trapped there
being a weak man also here we can see
that George is wearing glasses Ras in
the alternate 85 he doesn't have them
anymore according time I'm DB trivia
this is because he could afford to get
contact lenses so instead he just wears
them Eric also pointed out that we can
see he's got gray hair whereas in the
earli versions a slick back look makes
it seem darker this is given by the
grease in the product which in itself
was a big thing in the 50s now Biff
blames him for not saying the car had a
blind spot and that he spilled beer all
over himself which means McFly's got to
pay his cleaning Bill he also have some
really good lines here that pay off much
later when we get to the diner hello
hello anybody home do till Monday hello
hello anybody home think McFly think
think
McFly I got to have time to get them
retied do you realize what would happen
if I handed my report rep in your
handwriting I got to have time to recopy
it you realize what would happen if I
hand in my homework in your handwriting
I'll get fired I'll get kicked out of
school you wouldn't want that to happen
would you you wouldn't want that to
happen would you would you of course not
Biff would you well now of course not I
wouldn't want that to happen now look
I'll uh so what are you looking at
Butthead those reports on up tonight and
I'll run them on over first thing
tomorrow all right okay Biff well I'll
uh I'll finish set on up tonight and
then I'll uh bring it over first thing
tomorrow morning hey not too early I
sleep in Saturday oh M your shoes untied
okay not too early I sleep in Sundays oh
mfly your shoes on tied don't be so
gullible
McFly don't be so gullible McFly I don't
want to see you in here again George
stands and admits that he's not good at
confrontation and during this we see his
fist clenching up this is almost like
he's trying to throw a punch and
thinking back to what he should have
done when he was a teen the car being
toled means M can't take the trip and
George's weaknesses are affecting his
life too from here we cut to George
eating a box of peanut brittle which
looks worse than some of the videos we
put out and there was actually a deleted
scene in the film where he bought a case
that he didn't want from a neighbor this
was to show that he would just do what
he was told but it was already spelled
out in the prior scene so they ended up
cutting it at this point they start
watching a show which is something and
also pops up during the 50s Lorraine
ends up slamming Down A Cake which is
supposed to celebrate her brother
they're getting out of jail
unfortunately man didn't end up making
it out and we meet this character back
in the past you're my Uncle
Joey got get used to these bars kid
obviously the bars are well well you get
that but I love how he's wearing black
and white as well just like a prison
uniform now Mar's family are kind of
down on their luck with his brother
working in a fast food restaurant and
also taking the bus at the end this is
the complete opposite with George's
change affecting the whole bunch
Lorraine then recounts how she and
George met with both the ball and
thunderstorm also getting mentioned know
it was then that I realized that I was
going to spend the rest of my life with
him and take notice of the life box
there too with a game playing off the
line that we've just heard cut to M's
room and next to the clock we can also
see Pepsi free this was a version of the
drink that didn't have any caffeine in
it and it's what mody later tries to
order at the diner right give me a Pepsi
free you want a Pepsi pal you're going
to pay for
as the camera pulls out as well we can
see a big version of the photo that Mari
later has of his siblings now at this
point he travels to the Twin Pine Mall
which leads us into to watch the most
famous Easter egg of all time doc
says oh man Peabody on all of this now
when M travels back to the ' 50s he
knocks over one of the pine trees this
is later revealed to be at the Peabody
Farm which we can see by the mailbox
outside when muddy returns here at the
end we can see the MS Now call Lone Pine
Mall and this is due to Marty knocking
over one of the trees in the past
Peabody's son is also called Sherman
which I found out from the making of
notes this is a nod to a Big Show 1959's
peabod in probable history that involved
Sherman and his dog Mr peabod they
travel through time to get to certain
points in history and according to the
trivia on the 2014 film the characters
also travel back at 88 mph haven't seen
it but that's a pretty cool no and Bob
Gil also talked about how on October 685
how people showed up to the mall
expecting Marty to arrive he didn't and
sometimes patience doesn't pay off now
dark also explains that DeLorean needs
1.21 GW of power before Einstein arrives
at 121 according to IMDb jigawatts was
mispronounced from gigawatt and this was
due to a science official the creative
team hired basically just saying it that
way Einstein getting sensory times also
similar how dogs were used on space
missions in early orbits to test whether
flights were safe safe for humans after
sending him Einstein's Z return and this
leaves the car completely covered in ice
I feel like this might be down to a
going against entropy which creates a
frosted effect all around the car
something similar was seen in tenant
when an explosion was reversed which
then created ice Zuck also reveals what
happened the day thought of time travel
I was standing on the edge of my toilet
hanging a clock I slipped hit my head on
the edge of the sink and when I came too
I had a revelation and this kind of
reminds me of what happened with Isaac
Newton when he discovered gravity later
on when Marty arrives at his house we
can also see he's got a big bandage on
his head from it now from here we get
the first of many things that were
referenced in Avengers endgame as I'm
sure you know there is a bit about how
back to the feature 2 is a bunch of
[__] but here we also see the
plutonium's red fluid this is what the
pin particles were designed on and it's
not the only thing here that would pay
off down the line doc talks about how he
wants to travel into the future and see
who ends up winning the World Series
Back to the Future 2 of course involves
the future and it also has has a big
plot centered around sports games either
way dark brown starts to Rattle off his
plans for the video and we can see he's
got a red notepad in his pocket this is
actually a one for Gremlins which Steven
Spielberg also helped produce at this
point the terrorist shows up which leads
Brown to say he doesn't know how they
found him oh my God they found me I
don't know how but they found me it's
probably cuz you got your name printed
on this side of the van mate anyway it
leads to him dying and Marty driving off
hitting 88 mph he watches he's Tak back
to the past to play some shitty games
that suck ass sorry couldn't help myself
now after crashing into the farm peab
buddy thinks it might be an alien and
the DeLorean was actually chosen because
it looked a bit like a spacecraft shout
outs to you say the little man on Reddit
for pointing out that the delorean's
designer also gets a little ND in the
credit there we can see he's credited as
being a time travel consultant which is
a nice little joke if if you stick
around and watch them now the
speedometer was also change too with
they're getting a top speed of 95
instead of of the original 85 this means
that they can show it goes up to 88
rather than just hitting 85 and then not
going past it Marty then ends up
traveling to Li State before he wanders
into town here we see a poster at the
cinema with Ronald Reagan's name on it
which Le gets reference when talking
about the president who's president of
the United States in
1985 Ronald Reagan the scene was
actually shut to resemble a Twilight
Zone episode where is everybody which
has a man wandering into a Town Square
looking confused both were shot in the
same pack L at Universal with the
creative team deliberately giving an odd
to it now here we catch several things
we saw in 1985 including the Texico
garage and the clock tower which now
works along with this we also have the
sign for Hill Valley which popped up at
the 6 minute and 37 Mark in 1985 here
the slogan is a nice place to live
whereas in the past or the future I'm
guessing it's not because that's been
taken away now the dinam M meets his dad
and Biff along with Billy Zayn who plays
the character a match man doesn't get
any lines in the film but he carries
around a match stick in his mouth which
makes him look cool so I might start
doing it too we also meet Goldie who's
inspired to be may but since it happened
anyway he would have done this without
mty now at this point mty realizes his
dad was a Peeping Tom which is a bit
weird but either way he ends up getting
hit by his Grandad's car which means
that he swaps places with George he says
Stella another one of these damn kids
jumped in front of my car would you
makes me think that he might have hit
George before woken up by his mother he
thinks it's all just been a bad dream
but it's your worst nightmare mate cuz
your mom's trying to [__] you that's
right baby it's an incest story
ow and she calls him Calvin Klein
because that's what was stitched into
his underwear which was the fashion at
the time in the translated versions they
changed this to Levi struss in Spain
with it being Pierre codin and France
because Klein wasn't know outside of the
US now line she's a bit full on so you
can see how she would have woed a
pushover like George girls taking cheeky
little looks and you can even catch in
the mirror peeping at Marty as he goes
to put his pants on around the table
they roll in the television with this
dinner echoing the war that the family
had before this is showing the same
episode of The Honeymooners which also
aired during 1955 after being freaked
out by his mom pitching his leg he ends
up leaving and we then get this line you
ever have a kid who acts that way I'll
the you now after he heads at to Doc
Brown's Manor we see the garage before
them panning up to the bigger house
inside man's got a different dog with
this one being named after kernus Duck's
also rocking a mind reading device but
there's actually the possibility that
this might work you come here from a
great distance you want me to buy a
subscription to the Saturday evening
post you want me to make a donation to
the Coast Guard youth auxiliary for
distances Mod's travel from the future
and this Saturday evening posts what mty
used to read the date on as for the
Coast Guard man's rocking a life
preserver and he explained he was a
sailor to not get any suspicion so maybe
it does work but either way he doesn't
buy modes from the future class of 1984
pretty mediocre photographic fakery they
cut off your brother's hair as we know
the photo starts to fade as time changes
with his brother slowly disappearing as
the P starts to alter also if you zoom
in on the photo you can see his
brother's hair is indeed starting to
fade which is a really cool detail now
Doc then talks about Ronald re and asks
if Jane Wyman's the first lady however
by 1955 Reagan was married to Nancy so
the timing of this it is a bit off
Reagan however really loved this line
and when he was watching it he asked
them to replay the scene Ronald was such
a big fan of the movie he even quoted it
during his State of Union Address never
has there been a more exciting time to
be alive a Time of rousing Wonder and
heroic
achievement as they said in the film
Back to the Future where we going we
don't need roads after revealing he
knows about the flux capacitor we see
his doc starts to believe him and they
drive to where the delorean's hidden out
I love the eeriness of this entire scene
and it then leads into them replaying
the tape of the time machine doc then
asks what he's wearing well this this is
radiation Su of course because I want to
fall out from the atomic Wars this of
course comes in the wake of the
invention of the atomic bomb and there
was worry that it would lead to more and
more Wars when first exiting the car M
asks if docs got a devour suit who were
Bann in the ' 80s known for wearing them
on stage Brown then says no wonder your
president has to be an actor he's got to
look good on television this was
actually a little joke about JFK who in
the debates was said to look so good
that it helped him get elected realizing
he can't generate the power to send him
back due to the lack of plutonium the
pair then realize they can use lightning
to send him back to the future although
they want mody to lie low they realize
he can't because he's slowly being
erased traveling to the high school we
see before the 80s hit and it ended up
get getting covered in graffiti huge
shout out to Tokyo no and Reddit for
pointing out that when they first see
George we can also see a poster with Ron
Woodward on it this is an OD to ronal T
Woodward who worked as a key grab on
this and the other movies now other
schools pretty much the same there's one
key defs we see in the ball later on the
gym is different to the one mod
auditioned in but there is a little
poster that points this out earlier in
the movie when we first met Strickland
you can see a poster behind him talking
about the new gym there's also a guy who
puts a kick me sign on George his back
who later tries to cut in and take
Lorraine from him still though he stands
up to him too bringing things full
circle from here when he also got
believed by him my then tries to
introduce lorine to him and Doc is like
[__] hell mate your mom thinks you're
the most handsomest boy in the world and
not in the same way that my mom thinks
I'm the most handsomest boy in the world
realizing that the enchantment and the
seed Dan will be a good place to hug
them the rest of the movie then all
builds towards that Marty goes to George
in the cafeteria and look look at this
this guy over George's back keeps bloody
keeps bloody looking at the camera and
that's why you're not a famous actor now
either way George refuses to share his
stories with Marty because he worries
that if he showed them to people then
people wouldn't like them this is of
course similar to Marty who's also in
the same predicament in that he refuses
to send his tape to the record label
there was actually scene in which Mar
would put his tape in an envelope but in
the end he just leave this on the
dresser this was deleted but you can
actually see this envelope at one point
in the film at the hour 47 Mark we see
Marty leaving his room and in his hand
he's carrying the envelope This was
meant to show that Marty had had a
change of heart and in the end he was
going to send it off now Mar ends up
stepping into s Biff harassing his
mother so why don't you make like a
tree and get out of here this line was
actually improvised by Wilson who got
really into the character by channeling
his own life everyone describes Tom as
being an ice sky in real life with him
being a far cry from how he acts with
Biff however Wilson was actually bullied
badly in school and he said said he
channeled this into Biff to make him the
big butthead he is now Biff tannan was
given that surname after Ned tannan who
at one point was the head of universal
and the next scene we get this line from
George but I can't go to the dance I'll
miss my favorite television program
science fiction theater and this is
actually a little metao cuz the show had
an actor called Michael Fox in it I
don't know if you know mate but when
registering with sag you have to submit
a unique name in order to not cause
confusion with credits this Michael
added in the J with this being a little
nod to the actor in that
science fiction theater that night Marty
ends up going to his dad in the suit
which is when he puts on music to wake
him up this has the name Edward Van
Halen on it and this is because the band
Van Halen refused to lend their name to
the movie Eddie didn't mind though and
he gave permission to use his name and
apparently the licks we hear are
performed by him now you might also
catch there's a haird dryer on his belt
which he uses like a gun during a
deleted scene according to IMDb trivia
this was something doc left in the car
but it was never addressed so they just
cut that bit out they're also going to
have Marty knock George out with
chloroform which explained why he slept
in so much that he missed school the
next day now that has George going to
the diner where he orders a milk and
make a chocolate throughout the film we
learned this is called L Diner and in
1985 Lou still keeps ownership over
there it's called Lou's aerobic Center
showing how he ended up changing the
business now guess what mate how about
I've had a cold again so I've been
recording chunks of this video at
different points forgot to point out
that when Marty goes to pay for the
cough we can also see puts a guitar pick
on the counter showing he carries one at
all times that's back in the video
though CU of the magic of editing and
outside the dino we can also see a sign
with some records on it this is
advertising The Ballad of Davy Crockett
who gets several nods throughout the
film upon entering the din of the sun
can be heard in the background and
Lorraine's brother also wears a raccoon
skin hat this is building off the back
of the Davy Crockett craze which was a
big thing throughout the whole 50s now
from here we see George swaggering about
as he asks L rain out a lot of his
mannerisms were based on the naughty
Professor not that one the one with
Jerry Lewis that was released in the 60s
the GID I noted out with the white
jacket and the way George dances by
himself being in line with it guy is so
nervous he says density instead of
Destiny but the Ws broken up once more
by Biff Mar ends up saving the day
inventing skateboards and making his mom
fancy him even more sever of the moments
here would later be Rift on in other
movies with them doing a lot of it beat
for Beat Down the Line I'll talk about
that more when we cover those films
though but it always ends with Biff
getting smashed like it's a like button
now back at dos who sees he's trying to
watch the end of the tap but he refuses
to hear about what happens next however
as we know he'll eventually play it
which leans in with his acceptance that
it's okay to change things and just say
what the hell now we see he's mapped out
a model of Hill Valley which would later
be referenced in Loki when Obi does the
same thing for the clock tower we can
see that he's using one of his own wrist
watches which has a time set to 10:04
that's because that is the time that the
light in strikes and it shows that the
man's got some nice attention to detail
now you might also notice that just
before he points to the clock tower head
that we can see he's got a wrist watch
on both arms this was done to show how
obsessed with time that he was and I
think it's a really cool detail that
just helps to add into the character
with a little wind up car that pops up
in the franchise down the line we sees
this ends up crashing into the theater
down the road this is something that
Marty does at the end in real life
because obviously he didn't have the
room to hit 88 and then hit the brakes
the right that arrives asks him to the
dance with dog pulling a [__] sake's
face throughout now one of the major
questions people have about the movie is
how don't Mar's parents remember who he
is why don't you explain this to me like
I'm five Bob Gail eventually explained
it to The Hollywood Reporter and asked
them if they remembered a kid that they
met for 8 days at 17 do you remember
someone you met on holiday for a week
and chances are that that you'd probably
struggle gilen said that they'd have a
bit of a hazy memory and 25 years later
without a photo it wouldn't really
connect
now cutting across to the clock tower we
then get this line are you sure about
this
storm since where can weather men
predict the weather let alone the future
this actually plays up in part two when
we have the weather running on Cycles
meaning that the weatherman is finally
able to predict it other aspects are
payoff down the line of setup here too
with Mod riding a lettered to Doc this
is then put together by Doc and part two
ends with Doc sending mod a letter
coming directly from the past
everything's kept under WS literally and
we even catch Brown bribing a police
officer to keep things Hush Hush anyway
Jam to the enchantment into the SE Dan
and we see Marty nervously waiting
outside for George to show up however I
don't even think man had to intervene
cuz Lorraine realizes it's wrong when
she kisses her son which is a bit gross
mate you but your Dodge double it Alia
Thompson she said that she kept this
dress and one day her daughter Zoe wore
it on Halloween Zoe's often been said to
look a lot like her mom and this luring
cosplay probably went down a storm
according to the behind the scenes
trevia they also played a little prank
on Michael J fox at this point as they
had him doing a spit take but they
swapped it out for real alcohol man
ended up drinking it anyway and then
doing the spit take but the scene can be
seen on the outtakes way he he looks a
bit shocked now George saves the day and
Mar's enlisted in the band with him
still having to play the song so his
parents get together Marvin Marvin you
got to play see that's where they kiss
for the first time on the dance FL they
can't kiss they can't fall in love in
I'm history really love how they use the
term I'm history there and as we see the
band's called Marvin Barry in the star
lers as we learn his cousins Chuck Barry
aka the father of rock and roll and
Marvin makes a call to him after Marty
plays Johnny Be Good mod even gets a
song Credit in the credit which not sure
about the Optics on that mate but we can
also see the drummer playing a swing
style since rock and roll drumming
hadn't been popularized yet originally
this was going to lead to the dance
turning to AI which would then have
police showing up I'm DB trevia States
Mar would also tell doctor's secret
ingredient in Coca colola which would
then cause history a change upon
arriving Back to the Future everything
would run on cocacola and we discovered
Duc had invented pretty much everything
and had used the drink to make money
Mario also plays a Gibson es 345 which
wasn't actually brought out until 1955
but the movie is so good that I'm going
to let it slide mate I'm going to let
slide this one time Al though the school
doesn't necessarily drive with a guitar
shredding George has become popular now
with students even telling him he should
Rumer class president the whole school
love him and Marty tells Lorraine his
true name which he says is nice but not
nice enough to name your first born
after AO and when they're in the street
doc runs to the back of the shot while
mody stays in the foreground this
composition is used throughout the film
at several points with Doc and George
being the ones to do it symbolically
this could show that Doc's almost like a
father de Mari with these moments all
mirring each other the doc says Marty
has exactly 7 minutes and 22 seconds
which is a really cool detail because
from that point when Marty travels back
it's exactly 7 minutes and 22 seconds
climbing up the clock tower he's then
scared by one of the statues which were
originally made for the 1982 film cap
people here we also see lightning in the
clouds above them which had to be done
with models and this was due to CGI not
being Advanced enough to pull it off
lighting Fiber Wire they were able to
capture the effect and they also use to
make bride to create the wind during
these moments anyway Marty ends up
driving to the spot while doc
desperately tries to reconnect the wires
the DeLorean at this point doesn't start
and Mar flicks the headlights on and off
to give the morse code for S so
now there are few times few times I'll
be back in
time the DeLorean had its own sentience
and it refused to start up at this
moment it said that it's like the Tardis
in which it was saving it until the
right moment and if that's what you want
to believe mate good for you and that's
the time I'll be back in time the dock
sliding down from the clock tower is the
only scene that appears in all three
films this was performed by stuntman Bob
jks who also got paid for them without
doing any extra work anyway mody arrives
back in the 80s moments before Doc Brown
was killed watching the terrorist arrive
Mod's enabled to start the car andless
he runs after them all but he shows up
too late Duck's gun down and love the
way mty goes to open his mouth to say no
but his pass self says it for
[Music]
him so real that doc ended up wearing a
vest and in the end it's all finding
Dandy mate returning home we see his
dock goes into the future with him then
traveling out to the air2 15 waking up
in a similar position to how he was
earlier in the movie we hear back in
time over the radio and we see him
coming across his new life Man's having
quas horns for breakfast his he works in
an office and his mom and dad are
looking completely banging Lorraine's
lost way and it apparently took 3 hours
in the makeup chair to make the couple
look elderly George ends up getting the
first copy of his book as well and this
is titled a match made in space on the
cover we can see Mod's yellow hazmat
suit and he's bringing a man and woman
together who are sitting in their bed
clothes you get that one mate you know
what that means and we see outside as
Jennifer arrives for the sequel they had
to reshoot the whole bit because
Jennifer ended up being played by
Elizabeth Shu sadly Claudia wells's
mother was diagnosed with cancer and
then she went to care for her instead of
taking on the role originally we were
going to have George flicking through
yuk from the 50s and at this point he'd
see mody in the crowd man then said nah
it couldn't be but it is which was going
to be the line that then ended the film
however they wanted to tease something
else and thus they went in this
direction on top of the car we can also
see a Mr Fusion which was also used
years before in the movie Alien the dark
brown Powers up the car by taking things
out of the trash and we can see a can of
Miller High Life huge shout outs to Eis
cool and Reddit for pointing out that
this was known as the champagne of beers
they noticed that earlier in the film
when Biff grabs a can from the fridge
that this is just a can of your BG
standard millerite this George he's now
living the high life and drinking a
delicious can of Miller High Life
sponsors of the channel ciao when the
scene was shown at audiences it was
displayed in black and white because ilm
hadn't finished the effects still though
the audience kept cheering and it made
the execs realize they had a major hit
on their hands thus they moved the
release State forward and this only gave
the production team nine weeks to finish
it was a rush but they got through it
and managed to get it out back in t ow
the movies obviously had an insane
Legacy and I'm sure you're well aware of
how big it was both zcas and Gail have
retained the rights and both have stated
they'll not authorize any sequels or
remakes as long as they're alive which
don't challenge Hollywood with that mate
you know you know they've got the
snipers either way this movie held a
record for staying at number one for
three months making one of the most
successful films of all time would of
course go on to spawn two successful
sequels and I think it's one of the best
trilogies ever love the posters as well
mate and and I feel like Trilogy should
have poster themes just like this
because look how good it looks I bloody
love it and I hope you've loved it too
and we will be back with Back to the
Future Part Two you want to see that
early then please consider joining our
membership and for just 99 cents a month
you'll get early access to videos you'll
even get audio versions of our classic
movie breakdowns as soon as they're made
and huge thank you to everyone who
supports us we really appreciate it and
if you want something else to watch then
check out our two latest breakdowns
which will be on screen right now that
is The Truman Show and Apocalypse Now
which I feel are two of our best videos
hopefully I see you over there right
after this and huge thank you for sting
through my cold I've been Paul you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
peace